oh Johnny came through too yeah I saw
that hey Tiff look saw Johnny Chang she
goes hey a guy with the tattoos and I
was like yeah what about him she's like
is he a gang or something and I was like
yeah I believe so and I'm like he's a
pastor now she goes oh cool oh
[Music]
wow welcome back to another Monumental
episode of the careful boys where we
were in the new set and all six of us
are finally back together after so
long Anthony you know what's crazy so
it's been like has it been a full month
or less than a month it hasn't been it's
been two months I feel like it's been
two cuz we skipped November yeah we
didn't we it's like a month and some
change for sure MH and the last one is
probably the like end of October so it's
probably like two months two months-ish
I was last year the 7th eth block so
like oh for you was actually that might
even be more than two months like two
cuz I was thinking like man 30 days is a
long time without you guys really you
missed us well I saw your ass
but no you know what it's the routine
it's like it's perfect timing every two
weeks every [__] two weeks we get
together and then we get to just have
like straight up nothing else for 2 days
straight talking yeah and then you go
back to normal life and then there's
other other [__] you don't talk to
anybody no for real D after JK I don't
talk for like a day Sunday I just stay
by myself talk any Joe you sound
sentimental yeah I'm kind of getting
older bro he's changing dude I'm getting
gayer Mar's not though so how was uh
dancing for carlot and
la la is uh grand opening I sold a lot
of cars nice man good you had to they
wouldn't let you leave let me just get
this right out the gate the fomo that I
had for not being here during the
potluck was HT was sick that was
basically yourt
it was your idea we were so pissed it
was an organic Collective idea of all of
our bright Minds put together to do
something meaningful and the food was
good too you know something shitty food
everyone brought good food everyone
brought HS man dude people were texting
me they're like yo I see you there or
like what kind of alcohol you guys want
to drink and I was I kept on being like
Oh I'm sorry Andy brought bancock too y
bomb you know what that is of course
long caugh lady yeah and it was crazy
it's crazy seeing all guests together
yeah that was a tri usually it's like
all of us and the one guest whatever and
then so seeing all the guests and all
the guests looking at each other like
who the [__] are you yeah exactly I only
watch my
episodes but then seeing everyone mingle
like seeing like uh like Jared feather
talking like the cash flow doctor yeah
it's like what the [__] is that that's
freaking tight dude there were there
were two two elements that uh probably
gave me the strongest emotion of fomo in
in the best way and one was and I mean
this bottom of my heart I still haven't
met Tiff oh yeah what the [__] dude St
Steve and yeah I know just not being
able to meet her like made me feel
really really and all she does is bust
Nick's balls all day long yeah dude it's
great can we call her a different name
what do you want to call it I don't know
just something that's I know I think
it's good that it that's her name cuz it
took
over different same same but different
Tiff the ear Tiff Mrs the ear don't call
her the ear don't call her the ear Mrs D
this guy has to do things with her
sexually don't call her the ear ear I'll
call her Mrs dungeon call her Tiffy G
that's what's the other thing oh the
other thing was um the most beautiful
fomo was uh seeing you guys' group photo
but with Colleen and being like a I'm
happy that Colleen's there in my place
but it was that like I felt bad that we
finally had a nice photo and you
couldn't be there for real dude does
it's just we'll just Photoshop him it's
a it's a white wall anyway so you just
have him take a picture in another one
and then we'll Photoshop him inside
that's true and like actually like try
our best to make it look real I mean you
AI Bart into a grandfather clock I feel
like you could do it can we get a
picture of you in the jungle of LA
Holding two Vines and then we'll
Photoshop you he has to be at a golf
cart sales Center
in evolution of this or part was telling
everyone that you're at a golf cart
sales promo in La who did you tell that
to I heard laundry man opening that's
and I I saw the mayor cutting a ribbon
and you're standing there like and the
dry is going off in the back yeah
holding TI
pods dude if you want to hire kjas for
like the grand opening like crew to like
do the lion dance and everything you
guys got to hit up anthon right now do
you guys do lion dance that's tight what
if you guys did a black dragon yeah they
did a lion dance Su a black dragon just
saying it so it's cooler doesn't make it
cooler I don't know I you're wrong so
where exactly were you during the
potluck like where did you go dude the
the thing is when I was uh when you guys
were literally showing up to the PO
potluck I was in my 4-Hour layover in
Bangkok oh that's even worse I had two
4-Hour layovers so I had to go from LA
to Thailand 4H hour layover did you hang
out with lady boys that flight is uh 3
and 1/2 hours oh yeah and I was it was
up I was up at 5:00 a.m. to start my
Journey so I couldn't sleep well and
then you know with like a 3H hour plus
flight you can't really sleep well I
hate medium flights I'd rather have
short flights or long flights and then a
4H hour layover so you can't really
sleep well and then from there I had to
fly fly to Taipei which was 2 hours
couldn't sleep well and then there was
another 4H hour layover why are there so
many layovers just to get to La is like
apparently really difficult cuz they
don't have giant international airports
I guess cuz no one wants to go there I
Googled La cuz I was like I never been
here I Googled it and one of the top
Google things was La is the poorest
country on Earth or one of the poorest
countries on Earth really see why so why
did you go there how do they pay if they
have no money it was a Chinese
television company oh food exchange so
it wasn't a Chinese Golf Cart Company it
was a Chinese Golf Cart
Company Media Company what was the gig
that you had to do was it really fun or
what yeah I was I was basically doing a
black dragon opening dance in front of
aerom mat selling golf carts were you
teaching information was pretty that's a
whack Chinese TV show were you teaching
laan how to dance no it wasn't like that
basically it's a it's a a reality TV
show in China where a bunch of
celebrities get together um and one of
them is my boy who I choreographed his
tour so I came to last and surprised
them and then we just did a bunch of
like dance so like they're not dancers
by any means they're like comedians
actors and different rappers or whatever
and then I had to like teach them a
routine and then judge them for it and
then if they once I like designated that
they had passed I would give them a
small amount of money which is like
10,000 low Ian dollars whatever they're
called which basically is nothing so but
they didn't know the currency exchange
so they take this money they go out and
try and buy food and stuff cuz even
though they're all Rich As [__] they
don't get any money so they get to go
out and make make fun of the country
like oh I can't buy anything like can't
buy anything at least I can us to defend
my face cuz it's hot here and then they
realize they don't have enough money to
afford anything they come back and then
they have and then I make him do a 72
smoke battle wow what is
that it's a format of a battle where
basically it's like uh you go up let's
say all of us are in a 72 smoke let's
say me and Ryan start if he wins that
battle which obviously he will right I I
cycle behind the line and all of you
guys go up against him and if he wins
every battle it's a first person has
seven point I'm King of the mountain and
I have to keep taking you guys out
that's like shark take and I have to win
seven times it's like the Eminem rap
battle Yeah Yeah than yeah yeah dope but
uh but yeah so once once we did that too
I'll would give them some some more
money and they be able to go off and
it's basically a bunch of like rich
people put in like regular people
situations got it that's tight people
like see that yeah they like seeing
celebrities do normal stuff that's tight
it's like they're shopping at the street
vendor buying a lettuce it's like
watching the Michael Jackson grocery
store videos oh yeah and then all of his
friends and family had to pretend so sad
and he's like what he's like what is
this and they like it's a cash register
he's like
oh is that for Sam oh I just want to be
a normal boy like Peter P but yeah
office is [__] sick this is I I I
hope you can't see that in frame no you
can't you see it's pretty solid can you
see that really absolutely you see
everything on that shelf right there I
can't believe the show me proof bit is
still you can see it over here too you
are you how did you are you serious is
that the shirt or did you make another
one what I jacked one from the merch
room you can just steal anything you
want that's the one I've been stealing
camera and audio equipment for years you
could probably steal a lot of things
from JK we won't
notice I mean we even had an employee
steal a camera lens from us and then let
us borrow it back he just straight took
it and put it on not the nonchalant
reveal dude oh I knew I'd get an in
eventually I wasn't going to force
it it just fell into his lap but yeah
man we missed you the PO dude we really
did man it was kind of [__] you
weren't there honestly everyone was like
Dude where's ay we want to hear his
theory on 911 yeah everyone's ask that
so for everybody who doesn't realize
this Anthony was kind of the first one
to spark the idea that we do apoll like
ages ago yep and he can't make it to his
own party and then eventually he's like
you guys are going to hate me I can't
go cuz he's out dancing with Chinese
celebrities I put a bunch of
stipulations in my apology what was the
stipulations I said now I won't I won't
be able to write a resignation letter
okay I can't shoot a video when I if and
when I quit what if we want you to write
a resignation okay well that's different
we can come to a new amendment to that
but I'm just saying I can't I put it out
there that I can't do a reaction video
yeah
okay good that's pretty cool good I've
never said that by the way we need I've
never said that I can't I we'll get them
we'll get yeah you're famous for not
signing ND I won't sign ndas when I was
uh when I was texting BART to apologize
I couldn't make it he's like all right
man but just don't be coming in so hot
next time with these
ideas that's
bloody [__] it was a good idea I don't
think that should stop you it shouldn't
stop you in the future from having ideas
like that cuz actually it was a really
fun contributing no more [__] out of
office it was so cool too getting here
and like being in a car for 2 hours and
then going in a car for 2 hours to go to
the thing cuz I always stay right by JK
but then I was like oh this is even
better I get to go drive and butt
[__] I think it was just Glendale yeah
Glendale yeah nobody told me oh yeah he
go in the address dude are you kidding
me we [__] post so much in the group
chat I had to I was like there's no
there's no way I find this [__] I put
all this info in the chat I'm like like
all right 7:00 p.m. at this address in
on Glendo Boulevard like later the day
he goes so 600 p.m. at the
[Laughter]
studio pull up here yeah I was going
what did you bring to the poly I brought
Jack of the Box tacas dude a [__]
shitload of how many did you buy I
bought like 20 of them dude dude they
were so good yeah they're
bomb oh yeah well I was just like I was
like all right I don't know how the [__]
I'm going to do this I'm getting off a
plane I was like well wherever we go I'm
just going to go to wherever it is
and like I'll buy I'll punch you that so
that's what I did so did you have the
Uber take you to Jack In The Box first
no I I had him drop me off and then I
just looked around I was like Jack in
the Box dude why would you pull out I
know what Jack talking about yeah yeah I
know exactly what you're talking about
too and then he drops me off and then he
watches me walk away from the venue and
then like he almost hits me as he's like
doing the right like right turn and I'm
like Yo dude and I'm like oh you're my
Uber driver he's like oh yeah
sorry he was confused sick ass situation
he was so confused cuz I turned around
like a a bout face why did I drop you
off and then I proceeded to walk through
a parking garage that was cool and then
you know I found out uh you know it's an
an even more confusing Place yeah it is
it was pretty confusing it was a tucked
out like really dope Studio though that
place is cool bombass f a lot of vet
food so you would have uhet food and
Jack in the Box
dude what a what a [__] what was like
the worst thing that somebody brought
probably Jack of the Box
tacos but he was trying to be the worst
good it was like Jolly be Fried Chicken
St brought that he brought three buckets
of Jolly be fried dude I don't know why
I thought we would have way more food
left but it was all gone there was a lot
of people that showed up maybe they
brought food back colen made lasagna oh
yeah she made lasna Las was bomb I
thought she was going to bring casserole
or something kind of it's kind of a
casserole within the same family
appropriating that's like Italian
cero he brought BBQ chicken brought
barbecue chicken I only bring green
fried chicken this places it's always a
hitter people love it like what is this
where did you get this what a TA bring
who she brought Korean Fried Chicken she
brought uh she brought uh seltzers and
and Tios that's what she brought but
yeah it was dope she it really was like
an Avengers night yeah how come Nina
didn't show up she should have came on
your behalf she should have it probably
down the street dang that disrespect if
if you made Nina go would she have fun
at all I think she would have been
really shy and awkward really she
probably know smack though no or no I
would have brought her around she she'
have had fun yeah she she been
comfortable with you for sure but then
you know she would have been very like
like do my job you know what I mean say
hi to people shake hands and then be
like I got to go feed the cats that's a
good one talking [__] about that's
always a banger that's what they would
have done you like his photos and Hannah
honestly the the the [__] rack Focus
one where it's like fa in the front and
she's like in the back that's like art
yeah I think that's better than the show
Pro Photo you can put that up she was
really good it was weird I love smack
love Tiff love all of you guys' girls
obviously um but it was crazy seeing
Julia cuz she hates
us oh yeah I forgot oh you know who was
there Michael yeah it was [__] mind
BL I was like what the [__] dude Michael
like grew [__] hair to here dude he
looks dope it was cool it was Co
he's like Rambo hair is he still killing
people I don't think I think he gave it
up he just writes scrip I think he
retired I think he looks like he writes
scripts at Starbucks now yeah he looks
like a film director now he does look
like a director he's out of the game
there was a couple parts during the
night where I was talking to like I was
talking to Jared a couple times and I
look over and I see smack and Tiff and
they're talking but they're also side
eying and like kind of talking [__]
about me as they look over so did did
smack say
anything she say what she was talking
[__] about or did they I'll tell you
later I'll tell you later wait what do
you mean dude hey whoo who who who W
they're side eye and they're like I got
a verbal commitment by the way what do
you mean that that your chick's going to
come on she kind of did say that she
totally did come on where
here that's tight and she said that we
the the idea is we have to change her
voice and blur her face no CIA style
yeah we we voice modulate but everyone
knows what she looks like that's better
it's fine it's suggested we get an
actress with an in ear and tip just says
her answers to her no no no no you need
cuz you need there's no you can't
replace like a a man's woman's reaction
when you talk about the man y like you
could just have like this reaction and
you're like oh [__] I know what that TI
would light me on fire dude she was bro
she was letting you have it she she
that's her that's her favorite thing to
do these days is light me on Fire Let's
Get on the hot seat that's what I mean
still do it gladly oh Johnny came
through too yeah I saw that hey Tiff
look saw Johnny Chang she goes was hey a
guy with the tattoos and I was like yeah
what about him she's like is he any gang
or something and I was like yeah I
believe so and I'm like he's a pastor
now she goes oh cool oh
wow her voice changed she was like oh
wow Pastor oh okay I think the biggest
trip for me was uh Jason chenny in
interacting with his wife dude they're
so [__] funny he has a real wife dude
they're so funny really cuz every time I
look at Jason I'm like who would marry
you yeah yeah yeah like you're a sweet
dude but like
I I want to see the personality that
matches you and then she's like normal
yeah and I was like why you so normal
you thought she was going to be too but
she normal I wanted two awkward people
it's a track though but she's like super
normal and I was like Oh I thought you
were going to be
funny is she taller than him no they're
like a cute couple like if Jason didn't
open up his mouth they're like they're
like a average paent couple he's like
all Meek and shy around her he's like
he's like a little school boy around her
and [__] he's kind of like looking at
her and like avoiding eye
cont the conversation we were having
with the couple where Jason was he was
saying he's like don't you think my
baby's ugly my baby's ugly that's what
he was doing like that and then we were
like no we don't we probably don't think
your baby's ugly dude like let me see a
picture and the whole time she's like no
she's really cute she's really cute but
he's like my baby ugly like campaigning
opposite
direction and he shows the baby real
cute baby he's like that in real life I
was like hey Jason meet Julia jul meet
Jason and then jul oh hi I'm Julia and
Jason is like I've seen you on the
channel before and then like Julie yeah
I'm on the channel and he's like this is
getting
awkward like what the [__] funny dude he
said that yeah so you know they got a
kid right so they got um and I was like
oh that's cool so like did you have to
plant it out and and he goes yeah we had
to plant it because we had IVF because
my sperm is very
low I like all of our Jason chines in
fres
yeah we have a little different take
because my spurm is very weak and very
low count almost like a weird Donald
Trump subin was so excited to meet
Johnny really you know subin is like
yeah he was like asking him to take
photos and he was like hey can we Squat
and go like this okay that's what I was
wondering I was like this is the most
awkward pairing I didn't know if you
guys went through a pH of photos like
who's the most awkward to put together
Johnny's so nice cuz like we were trying
to take a photo of Johnny and soon jump
say hey Johnny come on man let's
do he's sweet so funny it is a weird
collection like Hannah kept saying like
when you look at this group it's like it
just doesn't make sense they shouldn't
be friends it just doesn't and I'm like
you know what that's kind of been the
whole theme of JK like if you seen from
the beginning to the end like every time
we get together it's like these guys
just don't fit like they don't dress the
same they're probably not the same
religion or anything and I'm like why
are they all hanging out together like
it's just the weirdest collection it
does make sense that none of those
people will ever hang out again unless
we like make them until we bring them
together but they had they had their own
interactions so like you know people you
see people like intermingling was pretty
cool and it wasn't like tense and
awkward like that you would see like oh
there's a bunch of Republicans and some
liberals here I don't know how the [__]
they're getting along but everyone's
like sworn enemies and then they're
getting along cuz of JK was there
anybody you guys were trying to avoid
actively during the pot luu Ryan you
want to go
first I was trying to avoid hasagawa the
whole time why but he sat right next to
me as [__] guy cuz he looked too
smooth with his leather jacket I can't
avoid him cuz he has too much wo and
Coogi so he's like [__] all over me
he's like he's like how do you feel
about us killing it so hard all right
dude oh Jared was updating us about his
Jerry situation dud he said after he
came up here like 50 DMS that night from
the Viet when are we [__] like just
straight up when are we [__] he was
like I love J Dude [__] came all
the way from Vegas he drove from Vegas
to come so jar the the
he his type is he loves Southeast Asian
women that's his favorite [__] they're
called Jerry and so the code name so
that's how him and his friends can like
uh go around gyms and talk about the gym
and then like his friend will be like yo
there's a bunch of Jerry's in here he's
like wait why why did they come up with
the name is it cuz the name is Jared
Jared so they just made it like Jared
and Jerry's yeah they call him jerries
and we talked about on JK news and in
that day like 50 Jerry's hit him up got
it
did any of them like sign seal and
deliver oh I think he did like 48 of
them if someone DMS and says when we're
going to [__] yeah it's I'm pretty sure
it's happening BR it's [__] that's
amazing hey this is an amazing it is
we're facilitating dude dude not only do
people get laid layups on JK like the
guests but within the fan base there are
people that have become married because
that was their first like pickup line
like oh you watch JK to or like they
like they saw a girl at the Bobba shop
she's watching JK you watch JK news too
and that was like the first thing oh
like our uh one of our patrons the one
that was a zoomed in with us remember
and then oh yeah they found common
ground because they're both fans yeah
that's dope D you imagine now it's like
it's like an Uncle Sam uh uh [__]
t-shirt at the airport and then eyes
across the other terminal it's Uncle
chin and then they start [__] each
other and stuff just like B Joe's face
start smashing and they're dudes and
they're like we didn't know we were gay
so good uh so now that you missed this
event like what's the next thing we
should do like social event that you'll
Poss what do you suggest cuz this is a
hit good job which month is your busiest
and we'll make sure we'll schedule on
that one
stupid I mean I think the boys should do
a trip oh that' be pretty cool just like
our own trip guys only yeah just this
group right here oh this six oh okay so
not um where you want to go not the the
the big pot looku kind kind of thing n
no no too many people too much money you
know too much whatever right but like
give us about 6 months to save up no we
can do something cheap an inexpensive
trip okay or Vegas but just like not the
expensive version thank you well let's
get a pet p house at Circus Circus or
camping oh yeah I'm done with that [__]
that oh no way I'm [__] that oh cuz he
likes to sh he likes to shampoo no he
just needs me connected to the Discord
true but yeah just I think us doing like
our own camaraderie trip you know waking
up at 5 in the morning hiking up to the
top of mountain we used to do that all
the time until there was dysfunction in
the group but now that there's not I
think that's a great idea but if we all
went to Hawaii dude that's different
from yeah I love it I still we got to do
the thing where we run June while he's
that would be that would be really cool
we got do that you know what's funny
it's like the two places we went and did
JK trips the most I just live in now
Trump trump to
and no that would be really cool if we
do a a JK trip to Hawaii uhh and then um
we steal the tip jar yes you saw that
[__] crazy we take turns oh yeah
there is a Trump Tower there is a Trump
Tower or it's a it's a hotel we go to
the Trump Tower hey that's Trum Tower it
looks nice yeah that's full circle right
there really good continuity although it
might be going away soon
they want to do a Rebrand are they going
are you space laser that [__] too I
think maybe because of the C the
clientele or I don't know maybe it's to
there's yeah it's a very blue State I
know we're in the 20 minute Mark when
we're talking about space
laser